hello there today we'll look at blurt
learning robust metrics for text
generation by tabled salam dippin
jaundice and anchor peeper ik so this
paper on a high level proposes a new
metric for text generation tasks such as
machine translation by leveraging a bert
model to produce like an automated
metric and automated quality metric and
they make this bird model robust by
pre-training it on a very wide array of
tasks that they can use synthetic data
to train it and therefore the model and
this resulting score is very robust to
shifts in distribution and they advocate
that this could be used in the future to
assess text generation systems alright
as always if you like content like this
consider subscribing and sharing it out
and leaving a like tell YouTube that
it's a good content of course only if
you agree so what's the problem with
with evaluation for text generation so
if you know the machine translation
community basically what they do is they
have these data sets where they
translate from one language into another
let's say English to French and they
have a training data set that is fairly
okay Ashley large and then they somehow
need to evaluate this okay so you have
like a test data set but all you can
really do is sort of calculate the
perplexity of a language model that you
produce or of a translation model that
you produce
there's not really a metric for
translation so the gold standard is to
get it to humans so you train on this
data set you produce a program let's
this is your machine translation program
that you produce from the data and you
you let this run on your evaluation data
set and you give the results to a bunch
of human raters these could be regular
people this could be linguists that are
experts in translation in both languages
and they will score the each of the
outputs of the machine translation
systems and
at the end you will get like a number
like eight your system is eight good the
problem of course is this process is
very very slow so the machine
translation community does this every
year and it is quite slow and is quite
expensive as you know it requires these
humans here to assess all of these
systems output and you want a sort of a
sizable output right because you want
sort of a a good sample of the machine
translation system so this is not really
satisfactory but like an automated score
like perplexity is also not satisfactory
what people have done is they've come up
with proxy scores for the humans and two
of those scores are called Rouge and
blue and specifically blue is one of
these metrics that people use and it it
kind of it takes engrams in the
sentences so engrams would be like
snippets of like let's say four words
after one another and there would be
these snippets and that the machine
translation system produces and then it
would go into the validation data set
and look at the gold standard
translation that was also produced by
humans and it would also look at these
snippets of size four and it would just
kind of assess how many of the snippets
overlap of course the machine
translation system has never seen the
label like the gold standard for that
particular set otherwise it wouldn't you
know be fair but you basically compare n
grams of output and gold and some gold
standard you can have multiple gold
standards and so on so this blue metric
is more of like a heuristic and it has
been found to correlate fairly well with
the humans up until recently of course
with the explosion of neuro machine
translation and especially transformer
based machine translation I guess and
but also the their their system they use
LST M's with attention these systems
have become extremely extremely good I
don't know if you notice but Google
Translate has been getting better and
better really fast
I remember the the first years of Google
Translate when people still made fun of
it I don't
many people make fun of it now at least
it's not a meme anymore so um this the
more the better and better these systems
were the more these metrics like blur
and Rouge have diverged from the humans
and they're not really reliable anymore
especially if you compare really high
skill systems to each other
blur tends to not correlate well with
humans and therefore we're looking for a
new metric a new metric that correlates
well with humans but can be evaluated
automatically and this this paper here
proposes this blurt can we just stop
with the variants on bird we get a used
bird for everything but you know yeah so
they say it's a learned evaluation
metric based on bird that can model
human judgments with a few thousand
possibly biased training examples okay
so what what you what you would do in
these cases is now the the creation of a
metric becomes a machine learning task
itself so what you'll have is you'll
have a data set of things that are gold
standard translations by humans you will
have the output of the machine
translation system okay you put them
together so you have the gold standard
sentence this is this would be the
optimal translation you'll have whatever
the machine translation produced and
then you'll have a human look at it and
create a score like this eight right
here it says this these two sentences
they match eight good okay so eight
maybe it's out of ten so this this
bottom thing is a very good translation
for the top thing like to match the top
thing or the human assesses the quality
of the sample and now you have a
training data set right you have a Z
they call I think this Z
and Z till there or something or why I
yes this is they call this y which is
the gold standard label this is y tilde
whatever the machine produced and or X X
X tilde and then Y is the label so your
task is now given X and X tilde predict
whatever the human would say about this
okay so if you can collect a few of
these samples right here of different
machine translation systems then you can
formulate you can make a data set out of
this alright
and formulate a machine learning task
and that's exactly what these
competitions have done so it's like a
meta meta competition now can it's a
competition for designing the best
metrics of the other competitions
basically and of course the difficulty
here is that the data set isn't static
because if you come up with a metric
such as blur let's say you come up with
a better blur you would want these these
these other tasks to use it in the next
years as well because the thing about
metrics is you need to be able to
compare to like previous years and so on
so you would want a metric that is still
valid for other years and other sort of
other slightly different tasks and also
for other machine translation systems so
if you just learn on data from now from
this year's this year's competitions and
in five years all of these models will
have become so much better and they'll
produce different output and that's the
difficulty your metric should still be
valid at that point and this paper
basically deals with the deals with the
fact that can you learn such a metric
from data that exists at one point in
time that will be robust to shifts in
distribution so in five years the
machine translation systems they're
better they maybe use different language
constructs to translate certain things
because that's they assess that better
can you still make a good judgment about
which one
which of these systems is better than
the other system can you still assess
how humans would rate these systems and
they're saying that they found the
method to do this this blurt as they
said not only have they found the method
but their method only uses a few
thousand possibly biased training
examples and they do this via a new pre
training scheme so they say a key aspect
of our approach is a novel pre training
scheme that uses millions of synthetic
examples to help the model generalize
now why is it important that it only
uses a few thousand training examples
because these are generated by humans
right and humans are expensive so and
and it's not like like like imagenet you
do it once you have it for for 20 years
this is done year after year and you
need real experts like translation
experts so this is expensive so the
fewer of these actual training examples
that the thing can can be efficient on
the better so they circumvent this by
using they say millions of synthetic
examples to help the model generalize
they do this in a pre training step they
stay blurt provides state-of-the-art
results on the last three years of the
WMT metrics shared tasks now this is
this this is this meta task where you're
asked to come up with a metric for the
other tasks and the web energy
competition dataset in contrast to a
vanilla bird based approach yield
superior results even when the training
data scarce and out of distribution
right so let's have a look at what they
do okay so they say what what do we need
to do to fine-tune bird for quality
evaluation now if you don't know what
bert is bert is this it's basically a
model that takes in a bunch of text so
you have a bunch of text and then it's a
model
is a transformer I've made a video on it
if you if you want to check that out and
then you get as output you get like a
sequence of vectors but important most
of the time is only the first one which
you then use in a subsequent task for
example if you want to do classification
you would output you would put a
classification layer on top to classify
it into certain classes if you want to
do regression you do that you can do
other things with these outputs right
here but for this particular paper only
this GLS output is irrelevant
okay so you would input this pair of
gold standard and output of the machine
and the output would be a output Y which
is either a number or a class label and
in this case it's a number okay so you
input right here you input these these
two things and out comes this whole
sequence and you only you take the CLS
output vector and you put it through a
linear layer right here
weights and bias and that would output
the number Y and the number Y you train
to be as close as possible to the human
to what the human would say about this
pair X the gold standard and X tilde the
output of the system okay so this is
what you would do if you were simply
going about it just take Bert take the D
model so birds really good at language
right take the model and train it on
this data set they say however fine
tuning Bert requires a sizable amount of
iid data okay we don't have that in
these tasks which is less than ideal for
a metric that should generalize to a
variety of tasks and model drift so this
problem with just applying Bert here is
that way they say it you don't have
enough data and it's it won't be a
robust solution it will only work for
this particular data set that you train
on the solution they say is a
pre-trained on synthetic data so what
does that mean they say the key aspect
of our approach is a pre-training
technique that we use to warm up birth
before fine-tuning on the rating data
and you might know bert bert training
which is where you do this masked
language model pre-training right so if
you are given a piece of text let's say
you're given this piece of text right
here what you would do is you would drop
out a couple of words like this one and
this one and ask Bert to reconstruct
it's like a denoising auto-encoder and
that way we're learned sort of about
language in in this particular way now
they they're not saying you should
replace that what they're saying is
first first you should do this masked
language model pre-training second you
should do their synthetic pre training
and third you should do the fine tuning
tuning now if in the in the naive
approach you would skip this step too
right so their claim is that by
introduction of this step to that you
could be a lot better and a lot more
robust because you've already had like
so you're already exposed to information
in this step that would make you more
robust to distribution shifts in this
fine tuning data later okay now I've
shortened to interlude right here I've
advocated for this step to be called
priming priming because otherwise you
always have to say like okay preach I
want a pre trained bird but I don't mean
like pre pre training like I don't mean
this dish this is already called pre
training I want to pre train after
freight train so I just vote for this to
be called priming I'm I have no idea
like if you come up with stuff like this
probably you've heard it somewhere so
I'm I guess I'm
I might not be the inventor of this but
it is a good sounding word and it sort
of fits right okay so they say we
generate a large number of synthetic
reference candidate pairs so what
they're going to do is they're going to
take a bunch of text and in their case I
think it's Wikipedia and for each
Wikipedia article they're going to so
they they take Wikipedia they're going
to draw sentences or samples or
paragraphs from Wikipedia and these are
going to be Y or Z and then they're
going to kind of muddle with them a bit
they're going to disturb them a bit to
make them a bit different to make them
go Z tilde and this simulates that the
difference between what the machine
translation outputs and the gold
standard sentence they're usually not
exactly the same right if you translate
a sentence there are many ways you can
do it and their goal is to sort of
produce a data set that has sentences
and sort of perturbed versions of the
sentence but not perturbed like randomly
but perturbed in a sort of language
knowledgeable way okay so how do they
how do they do this they have three
different ways first of all mask filling
with Bert so what they're doing is they
take a Bert that can do language
modeling right a pre trained Bert and
let's again say we have this text right
here and they simply drop out two words
or so and fill them in again with Bert
now Bert might produce the same words or
it might produce slightly different
words depending on how many you drop out
you can choose the kind of amount that
you perturb these sentences okay so the
second is they back translate so what
they do with back translation is they
use a machine translation model now it
doesn't matter which one you take out of
they use any machine translation model
to take a sentence z
and then they map it to another language
say from English to French so this is Z
French and then they map it back again
with the Z tilde is now the French to
English translation so you need to
translation well first you translate it
to French and then you translate it back
again and that would sometimes give you
the same sentence but often it will give
you sort of a paraphrase of the the
sentence that you had at the beginning
okay so that would be the second version
that you could make pairs of sentences
that are sort of similar and the third
way is just to drop out words um they
just found this too to help okay so now
they have a giant data set of sentences
and perturbed versions of sentences so
earlier they're gonna do with that giant
data set and the answer is they're going
to take this Z and Z tilde and you're
going to put that into burped into their
thing that they prime now this is the
priming stage right this was pre trained
on mask language modeling now they want
a primer what are they gonna do they're
gonna take this CLS vector and now of
course this is not the final task and we
don't have final labels for these two
things so we need to somehow come up
with our own late tasks and labels for
them and they decide to go a whole bunch
of tasks so they go like they go like I
think I don't even know they go 8 or so
or 5 or so different tasks they
construct different tasks to perform
with these two things and this could be
metrics like blue or Rouge or this Bert
score right here so you simply calculate
the Engram overlap between Z and Z prime
that would be one of the scores it could
be the back-translation likelihood which
is how likely does a back translation
model assess this sentence or here is
all the things six six different tasks
okay so six different tasks and that the
catch here is so what would happen for
example with blue is you would take a
model and you would calculate the blur
score between those two things but you
wouldn't input that into Burt you would
ask Burt to predict the blur score
okay so Burt would be outputting B hat
and B would be the actual blur score so
you would train Burt to predict the blur
score of this particular pair of input
and so one you want to take as like the
input and the other one you take as the
reference okay and you would ask Burt to
predict the blur score of this to
predict the Rouge score you would ask it
all of these signals you ask this one
the same model you ask to predict all of
these scores for these two things okay
so you can calculate all of these scores
by either blur is like a script you run
or you have some other model like a pre
trained translation model that you use
to assess the that you ask how good is
this in terms of this particular task
back translation and then you try to
predict that score where is important
you're not training the model to perform
these tasks these tasks you already have
another model that's specialized to
these particular tasks and you simply
ask them to score the input okay you
have an entailment model that outputs
how much by how much does the second
sentence entail the first that basically
means does the second sentence follow
from the first and of course this is not
you know it's not actually proper input
data for that task but you can still ask
the model and if these are good
translations of each other if these
sentences match then the second one
should probably follow fairly well for
the first but at least you can if you
make vert predict that it will learn
something useful about the relation
between the two
sentences so the entire game name of the
game here is to come up with tasks that
if Bert learns to predict the score of
these tasks on those inputs sorry on
pretending one is the input and the
other one is the output or on the two
inputs and then trying to predict the
score then Bert would learn something
useful okay so that's that's the the the
trick here is to come up with these pre
training tasks and you train them all at
the same time and by doing it all at the
same time and by doing it on many many
different perturbations on these
different tasks you hope that your model
learns something some it's kind of
becoming attune to the variations that
language can have and what it needs to
pay attention to and then you hope that
if you then have done this then take
this model and then do step three which
is fine tuning on the actual data you
have you would guess that it becomes
very good at that data but also it
retains all of these abilities and and
generalizes better to other sort of
distribution shifts all right so that is
that is the thing here and they on this
task on this metric learning tasks they
do outperform all other models right
here and what I find interesting is down
here where they now test for the for the
distribution shift so what they're
saying is okay this is all on data
basically where you know we train on
training data and evaluate on testing
data and they're sort of the same they
come from the same year from the same
machine turn translation models and we
don't really know how you know next year
the machine translation models might be
different the sour scores still hold so
they try to simulate this by splitting
the data
and they introduced this skew factor so
what they'll do is they'll split the
data so usually as you can see right
here the training date the ratings these
are the human ratings the training data
is sort of distributed like this would
be the test data and the training data
would almost be overlapping that if you
can see like the dotted lines right here
or so so you can see the overlap between
the test and the train that of the human
ratings is very close now they say we
can we can skew that we can sort of
filter the data such that in the
training data only very bad sentences
are and in the test data there are only
very good sentences okay and this
simulates the fact that you know we this
might be the previous year's data that
we train our metric on and then we we
evaluate it on the next year's data
where all the systems have become better
and what this does is you can see right
here the bottom axis is the test skew
and the color here is the training skew
okay so what interests what what we're
interested in is to the right and down
the colors
so as these skew increases you can see
right here that the the quality of the
metric decreases okay the correlation
with the human ratings decreases but it
it still remains fairly well but
especially the training skew if you
update the train so if you make the
training examples really bad so to say
it the score just drops down and they
can show pretty well here that if you
add this pre training then the score
except in this extreme case so the score
for all of these it remains relatively
high and especially remains above the
blue score which is always sort of worse
right
so this is is pretty as pretty neat and
shows this power of
there's pre-training basically that's
that's the the robustness to quality
drift metric and they have a bunch of
other metrics right here where they
oblate and so on but I don't want to go
too much into that I more want to make
some comments on on this work so what
what I think so first of all in a paper
like this what what I would like to see
is like the extrapolation right here to
if and where this ever crosses the the
blue score right because I mean okay it
seems like yeah this skew of three is a
big number but who knows if three is a
big number right who like we can't
assess that what we need to see is
really the where the crossover point
between the models to assess where does
it where is it no longer valid and so on
the second part here is that my problem
with this method of splitting the data I
mean yes okay you split the bad from the
good but it's not it's not only that
these things are getting better so right
now everyone's using transformers right
everyone's using Burt for everything
right and Burt is a specific
architecture that is going to be good at
specific things at specific grammatical
constructs in specific languages so it's
the mistakes it makes a very systematic
now if in one year or two years all of a
sudden the a new model pops up I don't
know like someone discovers that graph
neural networks a really good at machine
translation these models are going to be
attuned to a very very different set of
constructs they might be better overall
but they're going to make a different
sort of mistake and so I think just
assessing these skill via just dividing
up the data in into bad and good ratings
I don't think that covers these
distribution shifts that they set out to
cover right what I would have expected
is something like them because these
tasks are repeated year after year and I
would have expected them to for example
tray
on 2017 and then evaluate on 2019 or
something like or show like evaluate on
2017 2018 and 2019 and there we would
have a much better assessment of a
distribution shift over the years right
so so it is not super convincing to me
and what is most worrisome is if you
look at their pre training tasks I mean
okay there is a there's blur and Rouge
but there is Bert score right there is
entailment which is also a Bert model
and the back-translation I mean who
knows that's probably either going to be
a transformer or ALS TM with an
attention mechanism which is the
attention mechanism is the basis for
transformers so all of these things are
basically going to make the same sort of
bias mistakes right they're doing to -
it's not it's not like there is Gaussian
noise on top of these things all of
these things are going to be weak in the
same sort of assessments and not agree
with like they're going to have
systematic errors in them with respect
to them predicting the human scores and
if we evaluate our systems that some are
also using exactly that thing right so
these the systems we evaluate they are
using the same type of models as here
they're going to fall prey to the same
type of mistakes and then if we switch
over to systems that use some different
right that so next year we have some
systems that use different techniques
they're going to be like exactly maybe
not bad in these particular things but
bad in other things and then this thing
will output a systematically biased
assessment so it's sort of a house of
like if you've seen these images of
plugging in the power strip into itself
and you have infinite power it's like
it's very to me it seems very dangerous
to have as such an overlap of
architectures and methods to evaluate
systems
as you have in the systems themselves
but I hope this will be regularly
checked with human scores and assessed
as to how much these systems are out of
sync or in sync with humans all right
this was it from me for blurt check out
they have the code available the metric
is available evaluate your stuff with it
and bye bye